good morning everyone
first off I'd like to thank by our
conference live for giving me the
opportunity to present at the clinical
diagnostics and research symposium my
name is Anthony Marauder and I'm the
chief scientific officer of rx and this
morning my talk will be how does the
soluble mechanistic biomarker for 23 ADA
assist in the management of rheumatoid
arthritis here are my disclosures and
here are the learning objectives for my
talk this morning firstly it'll be to
understand how markers are used in the
management of rheumatoid arthritis and
what the current unmet needs are with
with the need for new markers and then
also to understand how the 2 14 2 3 8 of
biomarkers assists with the management
of all right before I go into the talk
I'd like to say that if there are any
questions please feel free to ask your
questions throughout the talk using the
question and answer key over on the very
left hand panel I'll basically take
questions throughout the talk but
address them at the end of the talk and
if I don't have an opportunity to
address your questions I've provided my
email address at the end of the talk and
please feel free to correspond with me
by email and I'll do my best to address
your questions within an adequate amount
of time so what is rheumatoid arthritis
rheumatoid arthritis is an autoimmune
disease where the immune system goes
awry and the normal defense mechanisms
become dysregulated such that they begin
attacking the joints the disease itself
affects approximately 4.5 million people
worldwide and it has a female
preponderance if you actually look you
know at the distribution there's it the
the diagnosis of RA is predominately
female German with the ratio being three
to one female to male and the important
thing is that within the proximately
five years following diagnosis
approximately 30 to 50 percent of
patients and
not being able to work and so when we
look at the economic burden of the
disease overall it's quite costly to the
system so there's a real impetus to
identify your markers that can assist
clinicians in diagnosing the disease
very early on now when we look at the
pathogenesis of Ahri it's a
heterogeneous disease meaning that
there's a myriad of different factors
that that drive and perpetuate the
disease and importantly the path to
Genesis not unlike cancer can differ
amongst different rheumatoid arthritis
patients and similarly to what we see in
cancer as the disease evolved the
pathogenic processes begin to
differentiate so drivers can actually
you know the drivers can actually change
between early and established disease
such that in early disease certain
pathways are more intimately involved in
the pathogenic process and then as the
disease progresses other factors of
pathways will come in that continue to
perpetuate the disease and if you look
at this particular review by n McKenna's
in New England Journal of Medicine
they're saying that there's a number of
environmental as well as sociological
and physiological factors that basically
contribute to the disease such as
smoking prior infections there's also
some recent evidence that there's a
connection between the neuro endocrine
system that ultimately converge and
break tolerance at the level of immune
system and when tolerance is lost
it ends up culminating in synovitis or
inflammation and the perpetuation of
joint damage and there's much more
obviously to be learned about the
pathogenesis but significance
significant advancements have been made
over the last 10 to 15 years now when
you look at the consequences of RA you
know when we think of rheumatoid
arthritis most people will think of
rheumatoid arthritis as a joint related
disease and typically the patient
experiences pain and certainly dis
formerly with it deformity within the
joints and if you look at the image on
the right hand side looking at you know
where the arrows are you can clearly see
inflammation within the joints as well
you know deformity appearing and you can
also see the presence surrounding the
joint of actual nodules or are a nodule
set as they describe them but re is not
just a joint related disease it has now
becoming more apparent that RA is more
of a systemic disease as well
patients who basically have RA are more
at risk of cardiovascular disease as
well as pulmonary dysfunction and
overall when you look at you know the
lifespan of RA patients it's
well-established that they have a
reduced life expectancy between 10 to 15
years less than the average individual
but when we think of the importance of
diagnosis if we can catch a patient
early enough there is now evidence that
you can actually put the patient into
drug-free remission but the important
factor there is that it needs to be
caught early and this is where markers
like 14 to 3 can really enhance
clinicians in diagnosing the disease
early such that we can put the disease
or treat it more effectively and
possibly put it into full-blown and
drug-free remission now when you look at
what the current unmet needs are within
RA there's a lot of recent research
showing that markers can actually be
present before a patient develops all
right so can we actually predict RA and
if you can predict it is it possible to
prevent it and I think this is where the
field is going you know similarly with
that there's also a need to be able to
efficiently diagnose the disease very
early on and for this we need new
markers so if you look at the current
theological measurements like rheumatoid
factor and anti-ccp it's
well-established that 30 to 40% of all
RA patients have what we referred to as
normal serology so that means that
they're negative for rheumatoid factor
and for anti-ccp so a lot of patients do
who are not positive may not basically
be treated or may not be referred in an
adequate time to a Rheumatologist so
hence you know we need new markers and
if you look and I have another slide
that speaks to this you know a lot of
the new class
vacation criteria actually 40% of it
rely on Sarah logic measurements so so
really you know there's a need for
markers that compliment current
diagnostic markers so that we can better
diagnose the disease and then similarly
with that as well we need to be able to
predict who's more likely to have more
severe disease so but in cancer they can
stage the disease wall with an RA it
becomes very difficult to stage the
disease at baseline to delineate who's
more at risk of developing radiographic
damage and those are the patients that
you want to identify and arguably treat
more aggressively because you want to
prevent radiographic damage and then
similarly you know with what's happening
in oncology with the ever extending
armamentarium of new therapies within
the RA space there's a need to
essentially personalize treatment at the
patient level so we need to be able to
have markers that can identify which
drug to put a patient on and then to
delineate whether the patient is
actually benefitting from being treated
with that particular drug you know and
with markers will then be able to tailor
you know specific doses or delineate if
a patient is not responding that they
may need to go to an alternative class
of therapy to have an appreciable
benefit and this is where you know 14 to
3 can assist with this and this is the
direction that we've been taking with
all of our development programs now I'll
just go into the discovery of 14 to 3
and arthritis so the initial discovery
of 14 33 ada and arthritis was made back
in 2007 by Kalani at all and the data is
published in the Journal of Rheumatology
and the reference is there provided for
you on the lower left hand side now one
of the things that you know this group
did when they first published the paper
was that they looked at the expression
of the different family members of 14 to
3 by Western blot in synovial fluid and
serum and then they used the
keratinocyte lysate as their positive
control and what the group found was
that the 14 to 3 ada and gamma appeared
to be the more relevant isoforms that
they could detect by Western bloc what
they also noted
that'd be levels by Western bloc of Ada
and gamma were significantly higher and
patients with different Arthur types
than when you compare it to healthy
controls and importantly they also
showed in this particular paper that the
levels of 14 to 3 8 and gamma were 5
times higher in synovial fluid than in
serum indicating that 14 to 3 likely is
coming from the joint space itself and
one of the other things that they were
able to delineate within this paper with
that the levels of 1433 ada were
significantly higher than the
corresponding 42 - yamo so 14 to 3 ada
levels were consistently higher than 42
to gamma now with this you know I think
it's important to understand before I
you know move through the data what are
the 14 for three proteins the 42 G
proteins are ubiquitously expressed
intracellular chaperones so I would coin
them being very similar to the heat
shock family of proteins the proteins
xiv three proteins themselves were
discovered as brain proteins
approximately 50 years 50 years ago and
this is interesting because there's a
lot of evidence now that there might be
a neuro endocrine component to to RA so
this might actually be a link between
you know dinner endocrine system and RA
and these are some of the things that we
will continue on with our research to
uncover now the 14th 3 proteins were
named based on their chromatographic
Ellucian properties and as I previously
indicated there are seven different
isoforms that share approximately 50%
amino acid homology and if you look
across species that they're highly
conserved and when we think of RA the
relevant isoform here is 14 to 3 ada
and so the rest of the talk will Center
or focus on 14 3 3 8 oh so when we look
structurally at 14 3 3 the 14 to 3
exists either as a monomer or as a dimer
in bebo and the picture here that we're
showing represents the dimeric state of
14 to 3 a.m. so you can see in blue
that's dimer 1 and in pink
the second dimer it is noted there and
when the two 14 3 monomers come together
they actually die merged to form the
groove and it's through the groove that
14 to 3 is able to interact with the
plethora of different binding partners
and regulate a series of biologic
processes now just very quickly jumping
back to some seminal data from the
Kalani paper what what they also
observed was that when they looked at
the levels of 1433 ada and compare it to
NM p 1 and m and P 3 both looking within
synovial fluid and serum they actually
found a very strong correlation between
the levels of 14 to 3 ADA and the levels
of mm P 1 and m MP 3 and this
precipitated the idea that 14 to 3 might
contribute to the pathogenesis of RA by
actually inducing factors that are
intimately involved in joint damage and
to that effect we've actually recently
now published data in Arthritis Research
in therapy just approximately a month
ago showing that whether you're looking
at early disease or established disease
that the levels are significantly higher
in patients who have erosive disease so
when we're looking at the image there
you can see no vs. yes so no group means
that they have no rows of data or damage
whereas the S group means that they do
have a roasted damage and what you can
see there is that in the patients who
have erosive disease whether we're
looking at early RA or establish re the
levels of 1433 are significantly higher
so therein lies the fact that 1433 might
perpetuate processes that drive not only
inflammation but arguably joint damage
and to that effect we've actually
started to look at what 14 to 3 does as
a soluble Argand and I think this
schematic here is quite important in
understanding why 14 to 3 is such an
important factor within RA so over on
the left hand side of the image if the
gray bar represents the
membrane then everything below this the
gray bar would be the intracellular side
of the cell with everything above being
the extracellular side so now as I had
mentioned in the beginning 14 to 3
proteins and specifically 14 to 3 ADA
they reside as intracellular signaling
molecules and on the inside of the cell
they actually through that groove bind
to a number of factors and regulate
processes such as the cell cycle as well
as the apoptosis and differentiation and
within the diagram I've also shown that
a connection between the glucocorticoid
receptor and that's important because
one going back to you know the whole
neuro endocrine you know connection
glucocorticoids are essentially in an
anti inflammatory break you know if you
will in 14 2 3 on the inside of the cell
has a very important function in that it
binds to the glucocorticoid receptor and
stabilizes it from being degraded by the
proteasome and through that
stabilization of the glucocorticoid
receptor the endogenous glucocorticoid
can bind to the receptor and then engage
or elicit its anti-inflammatory effect
now if we move over to the right-hand
side of the panel what's happening in RA
is that 14 to 3 is actually being
liberated outside the cell and you know
the question had has been posed to us
well is it coming out of the cell
non-specifically
or is it as a consequence of necrosis or
damage and importantly we have data to
show that actually 14 to 3 is present in
very early stages of RA even prior to
the development of a roasted disease or
before it's actually present by by
imager visibly present by imaging so we
believe that 14 2 3 is being triggered
by some sort of mechanism that causes it
to be released outside the cell as an
early warning signal and when 14 to 3
exists outside the cell what we've been
able to show is that it engages specific
cell surface receptors that culminate to
drive or activate various signaling
Cascades and I think importantly you
know when you're doing in vitro
mechanistic studies it's very important
to use a clinically relevant constant
of whatever logon that you're using and
you know having a biomarker where we can
actually measure the serum levels of 14
to 3 has afforded us the opportunity to
design a very good mechanistic studies
where we're using concentrations of 14
to 3 as a ligand that are reflective of
what we see with impatience and so when
we stimulate cells with 14 to 3 and
we've looked at a myriad of different
cells what we're seeing is that it's
activating you know certain pathways
like the map kinase pathway is
specifically oak as well as junk but not
p38 which is kind of unique compared to
other and intracellular extracellular
guns as well as inter cellulitis we're
also seeing that it activates a KT which
is a very important pro survival and
metabolic pathway and then it's also
activating the jak stat pathway and for
those of you with an inflammatory
background you know that the jak stat
pathway is such a key you know factor in
terms of driving inflammation what we're
not seeing is that it's actually
activating NF kappa-b
which again differentiates it amongst
other ligands so when these signals
culminate at the level of nucleus what
we're saying is that 14 2 3 can induce
not only inflammatory factors which are
well established at perpetuating disease
such as aisle 6
aisle 8 and TNF alpha but it also up
regulates factors that are intimately
involved in joint turnover so we're
saying that it up regulates MMPs
as well as rank ligand and so the MMPs
are very critical and cartilage turnover
whereas rank ligand as many of you know
play a very critical role in bone
resorption so we think that 423 is
actually driving disease now when we
first embarked on our development
programs around 14 to 3 we had a single
marker and through our research we've
actually identified 3 other markers that
are intimately related to 14 to 3 now
because 1433 is not present
extracellular lee the body actually
itself recognizes it 14-3 as being
foreign so it mounts an immune response
to it we've also been able to show that
14 to 3 NRA patients is situated and
that there's sit related 14 to 3 at the
level of protein
there's also circulating Auto antibodies
that preferentially recognize the
Citroen life form of 1433 and so as we
continue on with our development
programs we will begin to assess how
before markers move together to inform
disease and that brings me to this slide
because that's a very critical slide
first so on the very left hand side the
talk that I'm giving today we'll focus
on the 1433 protein and the 14-3 Auto
antibodies on the lower left hand side
we've actually as I said you know been
looking at the Citroen related versions
of 14 to 3 and we've made significant
strides on that and we're actually
hoping to present some of the data
around the Citroen elated Auto
antibodies at the upcoming ACR meeting
in in October at the end of this year so
so for the purposes of today's talk I'm
just going to focus on the protein as
well as the Auto antibodies and within
the image you can also see within the
middle there the a silhouette of a man
or of a human and so we actually believe
that 14 2 3 because it drives up some of
these other factors that in fact 1450
should be targeted with the view of
trying to clear it from circulation so
we've actually now embarked on a
therapeutic program and are advancing
our drug development programs in
collaboration with the National Research
Council of Canada and we hope to make
significant strides over the next 18
months in advancing that and we have
some very novel strategies at how to
develop novel biologic therapies to
eliminate 14:3 you know from circulation
using a mechanism that would mimic what
we see occurring at the patient level so
moving along now when we started our
programs you know we had the view of law
our markers need to essentially not only
be useful for diagnosis but we need to
evaluate what kind of prognosis
information they provide as well as
therapy response and more recently now
as well over on the very left hand side
in the red we beginning we are beginning
now to look at France since the utility
of the 1450 markers in screening
individuals were risk
to see for instance if the markers can
predict who's likely to develop re and
so the view from a development
standpoint is to look at each marker on
their own in isolation to see how they
inform particular clinical outcomes but
then to begin to combine the different
markers together to see how they work
together in concert to inform you know
these very you know different factors
that important
or different facets that are important
front from a clinical standpoint so I'm
going to talk now about our a diagnosis
so we spent a significant amount of our
time over the last few years really
looking at how the 14/15 markers on
their own aid in the diagnosis but
together with current measures how do
they complement measures like rheumatoid
factor and anti-ccp in improving the
diagnosis of RA and I think this is
important to look at so these are the
recent the 2010 you know classification
criteria and I think the important thing
here is that 40% of you know the overall
score is ascribed to two markers whether
it be serological markers like CRP or
the acute phase reactants pardon me like
CRP or markers like AK pas and RF
clinicians are becoming more and more
reliant on the use of serology to aid in
the diagnosis and if you look at the
right-hand side of this slide you can
see that from this particular study that
approximately 30 to 40 percent of
patients have normal serology so there's
a real need or impetus for new markers
that can assist clinicians in better
managing and diagnosing the disease so
this is you know what we've been
spending as I said you know I love a lot
of our existence on how do the 14th 3
markers complement current measures to
assist clinicians and so you know I want
to highlight a few important papers that
really show the need for new markers
that can assist clinicians
you know essentially diagnosing the
disease much early on and what the
impact of that is so you know you can
see from these three you know critical
studies that there's really a window of
opportunity you know to treat RA and
it's becoming very apparent that you
know a patient needs to be captured
within the first six to 12 weeks falling
symptom onset to actually really really
provide an opportunity to put the drug
into drug earth sorry the disease into
drug-free remission you know and there's
consequences of a delay you know and
more and if you actually look at the
literature it says them a lot of
patients are being referred
approximately by your to and such by the
time they actually end up seeing a
Rheumatologist you know the disease has
already progressed so we need to educate
you know clinicians at every level as
well as scientists that you know markers
can really assist us and you know
identifying the disease much earlier and
that those patients who are ceará
positive even without clinical signs may
need to be expedited you know for
referral so that we can watch and see
what happens with these patients not
unlike what happens for example with
prostate cancer or sorry with prostatic
disease not cancer itself where if a
patient has a elevated titer of PSA you
know they monitor those patients more
closely I would say the same thing with
an RA has to happen where if you have a
patient that is zero positive for a
number of these diagnostic markers you'd
want to watch them a little more closely
and hopefully that's the direction that
the field will move towards so I think
you know when working in the biomarker
space the most important thing that you
know you need to assess at the outset is
making sure that you have access to very
well characterized clinical cohorts and
we've been afforded the a great
opportunity to work with a number of
collaborators you know across the world
who have given us access to they're very
well characterized cohorts and I think
that's what allowed us as a group to
make significant and advancements over
the last few years and as you'll see you
know with one of our assets the auto
antibody asset the auto antibodies four
to 14 to three having both early in a
stab
disease afforded us the opportunity to
really discern how different these Auto
antibodies are the four tenths three
antibodies are compared to act by an RF
and I'll talk about that briefly as we
move forward so here's some data around
the 14 to 3 protein as a diagnostic
marker and so here is a scattered dot
plot of both established RA and early re
as well as a number of different disease
controls and so the very left hand side
of the slide the re group were we're
looking at a hundred and thirty five
patients that represents patients with
established disease that were on a
diamond but were naive of a biologic and
then over on the very right hand side of
the slide we've looked at now 477 early
RA patients and that represents the
continuum of expression for 14z there
and then again we've looked at a number
of different disease controls and there
will be a publication coming out through
the Journal of Rheumatology within the
next couple months that highlights the
diagnostic utility of the 14-3 protein
where we've looked at a large number of
different disease controls as well as
healthy individuals and we show that the
marker is very very specific for RA and
I think when you look at you know the
expression you can clearly see that with
whether it be established RA or earlier
rate that's the 14 to 3 marker itself is
much higher in RA compared to all other
controls and using a clinical cutoff
0.19 the sensitivity is around 77% and
the specificity is 83% and as the you
increase your cutoff thresholds you can
clearly see that the marker becomes more
specific with a corresponding drop in
sensitivity and I think you know therein
lies a critical question - that we as
investigators need to look at you know
with some of these other disease
controls that are positive for 14 to 3
are they a false positive or is it
informing joint risk or risk of joint
disease as you know a number of
different audio moon diseases
have our a as a comorbidity and if you
look at the frequency of positivity for
1433 and you know the different disease
controls that we looked at they're very
much in line with what you would see are
a being as a comorbidity rate so part of
our impetus as well from a research
standpoint is to really truly
investigate that are these disease
controls who are positive for 1433
actually patients who are at risk of
developing RA as a comorbidity and so
these are some of the things as I said
that will continue to do but for the
purposes of today's talk we're going to
talk about how before tentative protein
and the auto antibodies combine to
inform an RA diagnosis and so move it
moving along now here's some data that
we've presented recently at ACR last
year that speaks to the specificity of
the 14 to 3 Auto antibodies and I think
importantly here and this was a bit of a
surprise to us when we were embarking on
our development programs if you look at
established RA you can clearly see that
the expression levels of stablished RA
are very comparable to what you would
see within healthy you know individuals
as well as away and when you lump all
controls together you know there doesn't
appear to be a difference between
established RA versus all controls but
if you look at the early re group you
can clearly see that these Auto
antibodies are much higher in early
disease and you know that's a bit of a
surprise I think you know to a number of
us who are working together on this
program in that you know these Auto
antibodies seem to taper off as disease
and Sue's and these are these Auto
antibodies are vastly different than two
markers like ACTA NRF whose levels are
stabilized throughout the disease
they're relatively actin rf4 relatively
non-modifiable so there's a unique
phenomenon around the 14 to 3 Auto
antibodies that we need to continue to
investigate and we're actually running a
study right now to look at in a
longitudinal cohort what happens in
early disease to the auto antibodies at
year from baseline to year one and we're
saying that the levels do go down
which is quite interesting but again
that stuff that will come through and
hopefully we'll be able to present that
at the upcoming ACR meeting but
importantly when we look at the
specificity of the 14-3 Auto antibodies
for early disease we can clearly see
that they're very specific you know for
early disease at a cut-off of 380 units
per ml we're seeing sensitivity for
early disease around 77% and specificity
at 93% so these Auto antibodies do a
very good job of discriminating early
disease from not only healthy
individuals but all controls now you
know thinking about the two markers
together you know the protein together
with the Auto antibodies you know we
started to determine delineate or
address how do these markers combine to
inform an already diagnosis and I think
when we look at this particular slide
here you know this is a subset of the
overall number of early RA patients that
we've looked at so here we're looking at
250 for early RA patients and we
provided the positivity rates for 14 to
3 the protein acta you know as well as
RF and you can clearly see when you look
at the first blue bar that runs across
there that when you look at actin RF the
positivity rate for those two markers in
this particular cohort were around 75%
now if you look at just the 214 to 3
markers the protein and the auto
antibodies those two markers together
identify 91 percent of the earlier a
population and then if you look at the
use of all four markers together or any
one of the four markers together they're
capturing 95 percent of the patient
earlier a patient population which is
very important if we can actually
capture that many that much more
patients then we stand a better chance
of basically treating the disease more
aggressively especially in the earliest
stages of it and you know we're seeing
this consistently throughout now I think
this is a very important slide as well
you know in that it begins to speak to
what's happening between early and
established disease with the 14-3
markers so when then early disease you
know we're saying that you know they're
almost equally
in terms of the positivity rates whether
we're looking at the 14 and 33 you know
protein or the autoantibodies and this
obvious is not a longitudinal study this
is a cross-sectional study where we've
just looked at early disease and
established disease and looked at the
positivity rates but I think it
highlights something very important in
that when you look at the protein
positivity for the protein increases as
these disease progresses whereas when
you look at the auto antibodies they're
much more prevalent as I said in early
disease but there's a very small
percentage of patients with established
disease who are positive for the 1433
Auto antibodies and in looking at the
literature this is not a unique
phenomenon you know to RA I've seen
other indications and other disease
autoimmune diseases like diabetes for
example where certain Auto antibodies
are much more prevalent in early disease
as and as the disease progresses the
auto antibody levels begin to drop off
and so it raises the question well what
are these Auto antibodies doing and are
they potentially protective and so these
are some of the things as we advance our
therapeutic strategies that we're going
to look at you know what differentiates
Auto antibodies you know in different
patients who have better you know
clinical outcomes and you know looking
at that I think this is a very
interesting finding here so this is data
from a earlier a patient cohort where
we've followed these patients over five
years and the patients were grouped
according to whether they were positive
for 1433 and/or the auto antibody so
when you look at the patients and
they're stratified based on the baseline
positivity and then we basically looked
at their radiographic outcomes over the
course of five years so the total sharps
floor is reflective of the joint damage
score and so when we group patients
according to whether they're only
positive for the auto antibodies at
baseline or if they're positive for both
the protein and the auto antibodies at
baseline when you look at their
radiographic outcomes over the five
years it seems that the patients who
our only Auto antibody positive have a
lower radiographic to judge trajectory
over the five years compared to those
patients that are not able to adequately
deal with the burden of the 14:3 protein
they progress more aggressively so so
that actually it begins to precipitate
you know our thinking are these Auto
antibodies actually protective and you
know when you look at it what what's
difference between the auto antibody
profiles in those patients that are only
positive for the auto antibody compared
to the patients that are double positive
and why is it that there's a tolerogenic
break in that the protein or the burden
of the protein increases and you know
truly if the protein is driving up some
of these you know pathological processes
or factors then it kind of makes sense
that you know with higher levels we
would expect to see that you know
patients who have higher 14-3 levels
that they would actually have more
severe outcomes and not do as well
clinically and so these are some of the
things as well again at the upcoming
you'll are in June that we're going to
be presenting and we're excited by that
you know and you know I think this kana
is an important you know slide going
back to this slide you know well you
know clearly the patients who are 14 to
14 progress more than the ones that are
just positive for the antibodies and you
know that's important to overall because
when you look at current serological
markers and their ability to predict
who's going to go on to develop
radiographic damaged current markers
essentially can only predict 32 percent
of the total variance and radiographic
outcomes so there's still 68 percent of
the whole equation that needs to be
addressed and so there's a real need or
impetus to identify new markers that can
aid or augment the current markers and
better predicting this particular
outcome and so this is one of the things
that we're excited to explore you know
as part of our research programs to see
how fortunately combines to predict
radiographic outcomes and we've already
shown previously at ACR that 14 to 3 the
protein itself
is a predictor of radiographic damage at
your 5 as well as it your 3 so there'll
be continued work you know in this
regard as well now you know one other
you know thing that is obviously
important in the field is the need to
personalize matter you know the
treatment itself at the patient level as
I was saying the disease is very
heterogeneous and there's a number of
new therapies that are coming onto the
market in doctors need to have the
ability to discern who to treat and how
to treat them meaning what drug do you
basically you know put a patient on and
we've seen significant advancements
obviously within the oncology space
where a biomarker aligned with the
therapy can actually improve outcomes
and I think this is the direction that
you know the are a field is moving along
and you know because it's a chronic
disease it's also very costly and so
there's reimbursement hurdles you know
that drug companies you know face and
regulators want to have markers that can
assist in in safety and toxicity
profiling as well so overall the field
is advancing quite quite aggressively
and I say within the next five years
there's going to be some really exciting
advancements within the treatment
paradigm as well not to say that what's
been done already is not exciting but I
think as markers you know or the
importance of markers comes to the
forefront Clint pharmaceutical companies
aligned with clinicians and companies
like ourselves will really work towards
personalizing the treatment at the
patient level and so what can the 14 to
three markers do in in terms of therapy
response and so I'm just presenting some
data here around the 14 to 3 auto
antibodies in protein in a small study
that we've done looking at TNF response
and this isn't an established re cohort
so if you remember back on the pre one
of the previous slides here where I've
shown that essentially only 11% of those
patients with established disease are
positive for the auto antibodies what's
unique or different you know about these
patients and so when you look at those
patients that are auto antibody positive
you can see that at week 15 the
patients that are Auto antibody positive
achieve a lower deaths at week 15 so -
for those of you who were not in the re
space is reflective of a disease
activity score disease severity so
patients who are Auto antibody positive
end up achieving the lower - and if you
actually look at the change in dassit 15
weeks you can clearly see as well that
the patients who are positive for the
auto antibodies have a better change in
deaths so overall and and then running
regression analyses we can clearly see
that the 14-3 auto antibodies inform or
mark response and so therein lies you
know that the 14th is the auto
antibodies confer a beneficial effect
and mark a greater likelihood of
response to TNF therapy and then when
you augment that or parallel that with
the protein what is the protein doing
what we're seeing here is that if you
look at patients at baseline who achieve
a good Euler response versus an
inadequate response what you can see is
that the baseline levels of 1433 are
significantly lower to begin with in
patients who achieve a good response and
if we go back to the mechanism of action
slide that kind of makes sense because
what we've seen you know from our invito
work is as you increase the dose of 1433
that you're stimulating cells with we
see that it actually has a greater
effect on the output of cytokine so
lower levels of 1433 arguably are better
because they may not be increasing you
know the cytokine sync and as the levels
of 1433 increase perhaps what's
happening is that 14 to 3 is driving up
some of these inflammatory factors which
might be one of the explanations why the
patients who do not achieve a good
response are not actually achieving it
because 14-3 is driving up you know
these inflammatory factors you know
paralleling that when you look
post-treatment at 14 to 3 over there on
the right-hand side of the slide when
you look at patients who achieve a good
Euler response what we're seeing is that
the levels of 14-3 are modifiable with
therapy which again is unique amongst
markers like RF and anti-ccp
that are not
typically modifiable with therapy and
we're seeing that 14 to 3 can be
modifiable with as little as four weeks
of treatment so in this particular study
you know we're looking at 12 an average
of 12 weeks and what we're seeing is
that a change in 14 to 3 correlates very
strongly with the change in normal
serologic measurements that are used to
assess you know disease activity so
whether it be a change in ESR you know a
change in CRP and a change in gas and
when you look at the change the
relationship between you know the change
in 14 to 3 and the change in ESR and in
the p-value that's very strong so this
is not occurring by chance the decrease
in 14 to 3 obviously you know may mark
or inform who is actually achieving you
know a therapeutic benefit and these are
some of the things again as part of our
R&D programs that we're going to
continue to advance not only looking
specifically you know at TNF but also
across different classes of therapy so
we are presenting data at the upcoming
you'll are meeting in Paris where we
show that 1450 not only informs response
to DMARDs but also that it informs
response to toast Elizabeth or the ante
il-6 in the unique phenomenon across all
three classes of therapy is that if you
began with lower levels of 14-3 at
baseline you actually have a better
outcome and so that Cana solidifies the
fact that 14 to 3 might be a mechanistic
factor perpetuating you know
inflammation as well as joint damage
factors and that targeting it may be a
benefit and so we're very excited at our
X to begin our therapeutic development
programs so that brings me to almost the
end of the talk and so I thought it'd be
relevant to client highlight what the
key conclusions are of the talk so one
we've shown you know that 14 to 3 is a
mechanistic marker that may play a role
in the pathogenesis of RA and for that I
would encourage you to look at our
recent publication that's just out in
Arthritis Research & therapy with the
lead off they're being Walter maximovich
we've shown that the mesh
b14 to the markers the protein together
with the auto antibodies are useful as
are specific and useful as are a
diagnostic tools and that they combine
very well with actin RF to improve the
diagnosis and to bring it towards you
know almost the point though no patient
is being missed at 95% of the early RA
patients being captured we've also shown
that 14 3 3 positive patients eye for
the protein have worse radiographic
outcomes and that if you begin with
lower levels of the 1433 protein and are
positive for the auto antibodies you're
more likely to respond to anti TNF and
so with that I think it's kind of useful
to talk about what makes 14 3 novel
amongst the other markers that are
currently being investigated with within
the RA space number one 14 3 is highly
specific and its joint drug if you
remember from the beginning from the
Kalani paper you know they showed that
the levels of 14 to 3 were 5 times
higher in synovial fluid M&C I'm
highlighting the fact that 14 to 3 may
be a joint drive protein you know 1433
itself as you move you know clockwise
around the image here it's a single
biomarker panel and together you know
we're starting to see that the marketer
you know together as a panel can inform
not only diagnosis but other aspects
that are important to clinicians whether
it be prognosis or therapy response
we've also begin to you know show that
14 3 drives disease and as we work
through our therapeutic development
programs hopefully we'll be able to show
that targeting 14 to 3 provides a
clinical benefit we've been able to show
in this presentation that in 14 to 3 the
markers inform the entire disease
continuum whether it be diagnosis
prognosis or therapy response and I've
started to you know discuss for instance
that the levels do change with you know
therapy and response and that 1430 may
have used as a monitoring tool for for
therapy response and as I said will
begin to work more and more aggressively
on this with a number of different
investigators and then the other aspect
does well you know and I touched upon
this when I started talking about you
know the sensitivity specificities of 14
to 3 protein and the potential
positivity or the opportunity and
Disease Control's to identify patients
who have autoimmune disease who might be
at risk you know so can 1433 predict
who's likely to develop re you know
prior to the essentially develop the
disease and can it be a marker in
autoimmune you know patients to
highlight patients who are at risk of
developing the disease you know as a
comorbidity and to that effect I want to
point out some data that we presented
that last years they see our meeting as
a late-breaking poster so this is data
in a cohort of arthralgia patients so
these patients were either 0 positive
for RF or ACTA they did not meet
classification criteria but they had
some joint complications and said they
were brought into this study we looked
at 148 of these individuals they were
followed for over five years and at year
five the collaborator Dirk Amman Chardon
Berg knew who develop Dory versus who
didn't and you can see at baseline when
you look at you know the 14th through
expression the levels of 1433 are
significantly higher in the patients
that go on to develop RA
than in the patients that do not develop
RA and when you look at 14 to 3 as a
predictor of RA development you can see
over on the right hand side that 14 to 3
when combined with other serologic or
clinical measurements can augment those
and improve essentially the prediction
model so with that you know and we're
going to continue to expand you know our
research endeavors in that regard to see
for instance how well 14 to thicken and
the different markers can serve to
inform or predict re you know so if we
can predict RA
can we actually prevent it and I think
this is where the field is actually
going and I'm very excited to be part of
that and working with the number of
investigators within the Rheumatology
space to address what 14 to 3 may offer
in terms of predicting disease so with
that I would like to thank
for your time this morning as I said I
will begin to address questions that
have been posted you know through the
forum if I don't get an opportunity to
address your question please feel free
to email me at a Murat at our XCOM and I
will do my best to address your
questions adequately in a timely fashion
thank you very much so now I'll look at
the questions that that are coming in
and essentially read them out to you and
so it seems that there's a couple
questions that have come in that talk
about how does 14 to 3 performance
compared to the marker CCP and so there
if I just basically go back to you know
that particular one of the slides bear
with me for one sec because I'm going to
find the slide here that speaks to that
we presented that early on and I believe
it was this slide right here so if you
look at this earlier a cohort that we've
looked at in this particular study we're
seeing the positivity rates being 61 and
414 33 and 67 for ACTA but I think you
know therein lies the question it's not
about how compares to a anti-ccp it's
how do they combine basically you know
to inform the disease and if you look at
you know together you can clearly see
that 1433 augments essentially ACTA and
improves the diagnostic capture rate and
the earlier so a question again has come
in in regard to this how was the earlier
a cohort is defined and so the earlier a
cohort was defined by having disease
less than 3 months of symptoms or less
than 3 months of disease duration i'll
see if there was any other question so I
think that was are there any other
questions because I believe that that
those were the only questions that have
come in just bear with me I'm trying to
familiarize myself with the system yeah
so that that was oh I'm seeing more
questions pop up I think sorry they're
continuing to come in is there an so one
of the questions that has come up is
there an inverse correlation between the
reduction of autoantibodies
and increase in TNF serum you know what
that's a very good question actually we
I don't have the answer to that just yet
when we look at the correlation of 14 to
3 together with the autoantibodies we
don't see a very strong correlation
there but you know we will begin to look
at that because I'm actually about to
embark on a study with a group of
investigators in the u.s. where they
actually have data looking at cytokine
arrays and so one of the markers that
they've measured is TNF alpha so we'll
be able to to address that and I'm happy
you know to provide that to you you know
as we develop the data and feel free to
email me directly in that regard so so
another question has come in what value
would autoantibodies add in the
diagnosis compared to the 14-3 protein
so I think if we look at slide 22 then
when you look at the auto antibodies or
actually I'll jump back sorry to slide
21 when you look at you know that
particular question there if you look at
the auto antibodies on their own the
capture rate is around 77% well when you
use the two markers together the auto
antibodies in the protein you can
clearly see so if you look at the green
text second roll from the bottom the two
markers together identify 91 percent of
the earlier a patient population so so
together the two markers can really
capture a significant proportion of you
know the earlier a patient population so
they're complementary in that regard
another question has come in is there
animal model study on the function of 14
to 3 ADA I we are beginning to
look at that people have done knockout
studies but unfortunately because
there's high homology amongst the
different isoforms there's a
compensation of function you know for 14
to 3 so some of our work will begin to
look at how when 14 to 3 is present
extracellularly you know in the joint
space you know within these you know our
a models you know what does it do and
we've actually started to work with bio
seek and they have a number of human
model systems that are primed with
different ligands and so what we've done
with them as we've actually combined 14
to 3 in the milieu of other factors to
see if there's a synergistic and
additive effect and when we do that we
can clearly see that by adding 14 to 3
and you actually get an additive effect
where it starts to induce you know
cytokines in a more potent fashion but
you know well as I said you know on the
animal model side will begin to you know
truly assess this in greater detail we
do have some data that we're presenting
at you are in a non interventional
longitudinal study in animals where we
show that the marker the biomarker
dynamics different animals who develop
mouth disease versus you know more
severe disease and obviously because of
you know the requirements of you you are
not to disclose this at this particular
point if you want feel free to get in
touch with me post you are which is June
at the end of June 15th and I'd be happy
to walk through that data with you
another question has come in now is the
acid commercially available and the
answer to that is yes the assay is
available through quest Diagnostics in
the US if you actually go to their
website and type in 14 through 3 ADA
quest has 14 to 3 as a standalone
product because of its utility in terms
of therapy monitoring and because it's
modifiable and then they also have it as
a diagnostic panel called dident oh
where they've combined it with 14 3 3 RF
and CCP you know to be used for
diagnosis and I think they have some
very interesting
you know data that shows the
complementarity you know of the three
markers together and in terms of
identifying REM Stan nades
I believe is writing that up right now
so another question has come in is Syd
your only 214 to the present and early
all right what is the ratio of
uncertainly to versus it related yeah
you know those are that's another great
question the protein is Citroen elated
and when you look at the auto antibody
profiles of Citroen later 14 Institute
both in early and established disease
the positivity rates are very comparable
compared to what we see in established
disease for the auto antibodies in there
so the auto antibodies are vastly
different so you know because we're
detecting sick later Auto antibodies one
would infer then that the protein itself
is situated in terms of this delineating
UNCITRAL and versus it related the
challenge there in lies where we need to
essentially develop an antibody that can
discriminate between citrulline and
arginine and so we've actually
successfully been able to achieve this
when we've developed a pan reactive sit
related auto anticipated antibody that
can discriminate between citrulline
arginine irregardless of flanking amino
acids and right now we're in the midst
of scaling that antibody up and once we
have reasonable quantities of that then
we're going to look at the burden of
situation in relationship to the total
amount of protein and with that too
as part of our R&D programs we want to
look at how citrulline 14-3 has a lining
behaves in comparison you know arguably
just to the noncentral uniform because
there's evidence that when the protein
becomes sit related that it actually
behaves differently and certain ligands
like aisle 8 when it's situated it
actually becomes more potent so we need
to discern that because as we start to
think about or contemplate our
therapeutic development programs we
might need to have a bit of a different
strategy in terms of treatment when the
protein is it related versus not so I
think I'm just seeing basically I don't
think that there's any other questions
at this particular point so hopefully if
I have a dress
you know all of your questions as I said
please feel free to follow up with
additional questions via email I'd be
happy to take that and I think with that
then I'm going to thank everyone for
their time this morning and wish you a
wonderful day and a great weekend thank
you very much